republicans critical of donald trump
often face backlash within the party and
today is congresswoman liz chaney's turn
to learn her fate in one of the nation's
most closely watched primaries in
wyoming polls show the vice chair of the
house january 6 committee is trailing
her challenger by double digits robert
costa's in jackson wyoming bob good
morning
good morning nate since the odds are
stacked against her in this deeply red
state congresswoman liz chaney has been
encouraging democrats to switch parties
and vote for her and here in wyoming
that is something you can do on election
day but even if they do polls do show
that the trump endorsed challenger in
this race harriet hageman is likely
headed for a big victory
voters head to the polls today to decide
whether republican congresswoman liz
chaney keeps her seat in the house
hageman will defend our border her
trump-backed opponent harriet hageman
has falsely called the 2020 election
rigged if defeated chaney the vice chair
of the house january 6 committee would
be the eighth house republican who
supported trump's impeachment to be
exiting congress
underscoring the tight grip trump has
over the gop her whole focus has been
against one individual whether she has
information or not instead of focusing
on her district itself house minority
leader kevin mccarthy who cheney once
stood alongside in the house leadership
before being voted out after clashing
with trump has endorsed her rival and is
meeting with top donors in wyoming this
week this is truly a linchpin moment for
the united states beyond the mountains
here chaney's political crucible has
drawn support from trump critics even
some democrats minnesota congressman
dean phillips has been urging wyoming
democrats to temporarily switch parties
so they can support his colleague across
the aisle what's at stake for the
country uh is its entire direction
we have all witnessed those of us who
are in the capital on january 6th
those of us who have now endured
trumpism have recognized how fragile how
fragile democracy
really is jackson councilman james
brooks is a self-described centrist who
registered as a republican to support
cheney she has character she's a real
person who in the democratic party is
doing what liz cheney is doing risking
their careers to come to the center
we're expecting cheney tonight to give a
speech warning that the former president
is a threat to american democracy and
looking ahead she has not ruled out
another run for office including one for
the white house and if she does that she
would have a national fundraising base
having raised over 13 million dollars
for this contest gail
right so she clearly feels she has more
to do but bob there are also primaries
in alaska today could possibly could
possibly sarah palin be making a
comeback how's her race looking in her
run for congress
gail it is quite possible the former
alaska governor and the 2008 republican
vice presidential nominee sarah palin
mounting a comeback running in a special
house election for the seat held by the
longtime congressman the late don young
sarah palin has been active in national
politics in recent years but this is her
first run for office since she was on
the ticket with john mccain in 2008
since then she has become an ally of
former president trump
all right we'll all be watching thank
you bob